I think Andor is the best thing on TV
and I just want to talk just a touch
about uh your work on and or if you
don't mind of course I definitely want
to know I mean you got to direct a
number three I believe three episodes on
Android you got to do the finale what
was it like being part of a show like
that which is so beloved by so many
people that is great but but obviously
that's happened after we made it but you
know at the time there wasn't really a
lot of it didn't seem like there was a
lot of heat on and or it felt that it
was slightly um you know it was just uh
undercover and that this massive show
has been made in Pinewood but that
people had somehow forgotten about it
and you have to bear in mind I am not
um I am not the biggest Star Wars fan
and I I don't mean that in any sort of
um uh mean way I just mean I I from a
kid I was but I sort of I just maybe
fell out of love with her or I sort of
hadn't followed it sort of as I um in my
later years so and I and I declared that
to Tony really early on I said look Tony
I'm I if you if you want is this a
question about sort of
um what's been going on Star Wars
recently I I have no idea I'm a little
happily go and watch uh the last few
films but I I haven't seen them and he
was like no that's great we don't we
don't want fan service we want uh you
know I I've deliberately seen you know I
I'm aware of your work and I like your
work and I want that work in in Andor
and so
um so that that's how it came about and
I responded to his writing you know he I
I hadn't I hadn't I hadn't rent I hadn't
read anything like that for for a long
time and I sort of forgot that I
genuinely forgot that it was Star Wars
you know there were no you know there
was no lightsabers there was no Darth
Vader there was none the force it was
just really well drawn out
um narratives and great characters that
I just wanted to spend and time with and
that that's as a director or me
personally that's that's what I respond
to and I guess that's where it all
started and then
when we were filming I mean you know I
just approach it to like anything else I
do you know just
you direct it I don't know
I think that's the reason why indoor is
so good is because you could it could be
if you took the Star Wars out of it it
would still be an amazing show do you
know what it is we should move on to
Shopper but I just really for me it was
a spy Thriller it was a thriller and I
guess look you know you know Tony Gilroy
I mean I love born and I love my bit of
a spy Thriller and I and I thought that
is I could that's what I lent into yes
it was in the Star Wars universe but it
was a spy Thriller and so I lent into
that
um you know that that kind of tone and
mood